for over 20 years we've been tactically
sneaking and breaching our way through
numerous rainbow six games and now
there's a new take on the franchise
rainbow six extraction which takes elite
operators and sets them against an alien
threat but how did we get here here's
the evolution of tom clancy's rainbow
six be sure to let us know your
favorites in the comments below
ah
behind
threat neutralized
oh
got him
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
hold up holding
fall
bravo go go go
contact
good work now use the maintenance tunnel
under the platform to pass behind the
train and get across the tracks
on the way
information
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
see around there
affirmative
there's a six excellent the bomb is
disarmed
now go secure the perimeter and dispose
of any remaining cultists i want it air
tight
alpha two this is six the perimeter is
secured and you're done there great job
people we're waiting for you back at the
base six out
tangle down
regroup on me
they got me
heading out
it's right
down advancing
down down
i lost them they can't be far go go
to me
oh
on your feet
oh
mr ambassador
so after we find the ambassador what
then
we issue
open and clear
roger
[Applause]
watch the door
versus priority too
flash and clear roger
clearing
[Music]
is on the bomber
if they kill him everybody on this
bridge could be blown sky high engage
nypd immediately are you ordering
training fire no time to radio
take the shot
[Music]
[Music]
assault
ten seconds
five seconds to insertion
putting on a show
[Music]
adding my plus one
what's going on with these nests
huh
me
uh
triangulate the source at the first
station
if you want to see more from rainbow six
extraction the latest game we'll link
our hands on preview as well as some
gameplay on screen right now thanks for
watching we'll catch you next time